Jessica Jones season 2 has been added in
its entirety to Netflix and since I
really enjoyed the previous 13 episodes
I was curious to see what the
super-powered alcoholic P I was going to
get into this season and just as a
warning this review is going to contain
spoilers having eliminated kilgrave at
the end of season 1 jessica is still
haunted by the persistent fear that
she's a killer
despite her closest friends reassuring
her that she had no choice she's still
tormented by anxiety depression and
loneliness
Malcolm her new partner 1 she's
reluctant to have and Trish her best
friend convinced Jessica to uncover the
truth behind i GH the facility that's
supposedly experimented on her resulting
in her abilities
this leads Jessica down a significant
path of discovery similar to the
Punisher the first half of this season
started a bit slow most of the episodes
revolved around Jessica trying to
uncover truths about her past with this
IgH facility we also learned that Jeri
played by carrie anne moss
has been diagnosed with ALS and a
subplot develops where she meets someone
who can possibly heal her as well as a
client that she's protecting who knows
this person and at the same time some of
Jerry's co-workers tried to oust her
from her firm under the flimsy guise of
this medical clause that says she can't
work there if she's really sick and for
the first half of this show it was
difficult to escape the feeling that we
were strolling through the plot rather
aimlessly things happen characters learn
a few things here and there but for the
most part it does feel like the first
half of the show is just Jessica
discovering some truths every once in a
while before the show starts to kick
into high gear after episode 7 and that
episode was a delightful diversion from
the IgH plot exploring Jessica's roots
with a former boyfriend and some
devastating familial revelations you
learn where she got her signature jacket
and why her company is called alias
investigations there's also some
genuinely affecting scenes between Trish
and Jessica when Trish was at the height
of her
drug addiction a major plus of this
season just like the first is Krysten
Ritter she is a fantastic actress her
range is staggering she can go from
stoic and proud to a crumbling pile of
grief
she's just so terrific in the show and
she makes every episode even some of the
more aimless ones watchable but the real
gem of this season is Janet McTeer she's
introduced as a villain early on but
halfway through we learned that she's
actually Jessica's mother that Jessica
thought was dead this entire time she
had been experimented on the same
facility Jessica was and her memories
eventually regained and she was looking
for her daughter Jessica always thought
she was gone and so the ensuing dynamic
that develops between these two very
different but similar characters propels
this entire season to greater heights
and greater depths and I just wish she
was around earlier her presence is
intimidating she's frightening and she
makes the entire show better she has now
entered into that holy realm of actors
that if I saw them on the street I would
be afraid to approach them because their
characters are so frightening like
imagine walking up to Robert De Niro
it's it's kind of weird right like
you're a little scared like oh shit like
Goodfellas and the untouchables I don't
know if I want to walk up to that guy if
I saw Janet McTeer on the street I would
want to say you're amazing you're
incredible but I'd be like just just
don't kill me so with that the final
half of this season became the show I
wanted it to be from the beginning which
is disappointing a major theme explored
by this season is how we use people
Malcolm uses Jessica to keep his mind
off his former addiction Trish uses
Malcolm in many terrible ways Jessica
puts her new neighbour in danger by
constantly asking for fake IDs Jerry's
one last hope for healing her ALS ends
up stealing all her belongings well this
is a compelling observation for a Marvel
television show it didn't always gel
with the IgH plot Jessica wanted to know
more about her powers Trish wanting
powers the show as I said gets much
better once there's this dynamic
between mother and daughter but the
first season had a very scathing
exploration of what sexual assault does
to someone and especially when a man is
very controlling of his victims
this season takes a while to reach
anything even close to those creative
heights which was disappointing it's not
a bad season I didn't watch this season
and think oh my god just end it's just
that some episodes didn't really feel
like they fit in to the core of what the
creator's were going for and so as a
result sometimes this show meandered
even though some episodes are pretty
damn good and overall I enjoyed myself
watching this season it just wasn't as
good as the first an issue with every
show in Marvel's Netflix library even
the best one daredevil is that they've
gone away from episodic narratives in
favor of binge were these stories almost
every single episode in this season gets
the most interesting in the final ten
minutes pressuring us to watch the next
it's one of the reasons episodes like
the seventh stand out as special amongst
the pack there are fun hints for Marvel
fans like one of the doctors telling
Trish she's used up two of her nine
lives after she's gravely injured or a
side character saying to Jessica I know
how you people like the team-up which
incidentally is pretty much the only
time the defenders is referenced in this
show which I also found a little strange
you would think those life-changing
developments for Jessica would at least
be on her mind slightly was I invested
yeah sure I was I cared but the first
six hours kind of made it hard to really
get into the show largely because
Jessica's case her researching the IgH
facility is something that she's forced
to do really Trish and Malcolm are
constantly coercing her to give a shit
about this case and she finally
discovers a few things and goes okay
maybe there is something to this so
since our protagonists at first takes so
long to really give a shit about the
main plot that's set up as a viewer I
didn't really care as much either the
Jerry subplot was wonderfully acted on
the part of carrie-anne moss but in the
end it didn't feel like it belonged in
this story which is a shame there's also
a rival PI after
her and he springs up every once in a
while his addition to the show was
pointless at best and even in the final
episode when Malcolm unexpectedly joins
his firm you're left wondering how much
of this is really necessary for this
season there's also an episode where
Trish asks Malcolm to film her secretly
confronting a director that had sex with
her when she was underage and she uses
that footage to blackmail him which also
leads to a few plot points but it's just
another episode where Trish forces
Malcolm to do something and he's just
sort of left in the dust which is
understandable because of the way his
character ends in the final episode he's
in a terrible place and you're like okay
I see what got you to side with everyone
else except the people who care about
you most but it just felt manipulative I
guess I love the character Jessica Jones
and I hope that season 3 gives her
something better to do I think it was a
mistake to kill her mother in the finale
because her inclusion in the series
brought about a sense of
unpredictability that challenged Jessica
considerably at the same time it is
intriguing to ponder about what they
will do with these characters Trish and
Jessica in season 3
because Trish could become Hellcat or
this shows version of Hellcat also she
killed Jessica's mom so that's not going
anywhere pretty I'm intrigued to see
what they do with these characters I
just hope that it's a little more
focused I'm gonna give Jessica Jones
season 2 a C+ if you were a big fan of
season 1 I would recommend checking out
season 2 it might disappoint you a
little bit like it did me it's not awful
it has strong moments it has weak
moments it just doesn't always feel like
it comes together but there are things
to be excited about namely Janet McTeer
who's just insanely great in this season
guys thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]